[Music]
who's the girl she's a princess
Oh aren't they all oh we've had a
connection but she has to marry a prince
back up where I need some room to work I
made you to look like a prince on the
outside but I didn't change anything on
the inside or inside we got you to the
door
do you trust me what did you say but
Aladdin has to open it do you trust me
[Music]
sometimes princess you just have to take
a risk
[Music]
[Music]
you stumbled upon an opportunity
I can make you rich rich enough to
impress a princess what would I have to
do there's a Cave of Wonders
bring me the land
[Music]
oh great one who summons me I stand by
my oath
loyalty two wishes three I'm kidding
Rustin
[Music]
hey can you make me a prince there is a
lot of gray area in make me a prince I
could just make you a friends
oh no you look like a prince
on the outside but I didn't change
anything on the inside Showtime no I'm
in charge okay I say when it's done
[Music]
really
I thought a princess could go anywhere
not this princess do you trust me
[Music]
human teeth
how did you get past the guards that was
challenging
you cannot just break into a palace like
you own the place
if you don't have anything you have to
act like you own everything you stumbled
upon an opportunity I can make you rich
rich enough to impress a princess what
would I have to do there's a Cave of
Wonders
bring me the land
oh great one who summons me I stand by
my oath loyalty to wishes three I'm
kidding restive do you trust me
well I dare do we need the top not
that's my little cherry on top rated PG
[Music]
[Music]
Buzzz fall
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bring me the land
your life begins now
[Music]
Aladin
[Music]
you really don't know who I am genie
wishes land
none of that ringing about
[Music]
you